on this episode we talk about excuses
the ROI of social media at virgin
reality you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
welcome to episode number 38 of the
askgaryvee show fun fact about the
number 38 I am 38 years old for 10 more
days I know I said I was gonna do any
more fun facts but actually all the
people jumping into the comments over
the weekend saying yeah I'm glad you got
rid of the fun facts it didn't bring me
any value made me do a fun fact before
we get in today's episode I just want to
make a couple of statements one I am
completely miserable about football this
has just gotten to a whole new level and
I just want to for once it brought don't
even know if I did this for once and for
all in the show before but I'm gonna do
it for once and for all a second time if
I did when the Jets lose it does not
bring down the value of the franchise
and number two I'm pissed
Joe asks can anyone create good micro
content how can you make sure your team
consistently creates good content Joe
great question first for everybody's
watching and/or listening I want to talk
about the term micro content it's
something I started using three four
years ago hasn't really caught on I
myself don't know how often I'm going to
use it going forward but the notion was
content made specifically for the
platform you know the videos and the
pictures the quotes the written words
that worked on Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram snapchat vine it was
the context of the book Jab Jab Jab
right hook you run
throw it up there throw it up there show
it I got it mmm you got it okay so you
know how do you make good micro content
how do you consistently get your team to
do it first of all content is subjective
right Steve likes Game of Thrones shows
I don't not that I don't like it I just
haven't even seen it yet so if you watch
Game of Thrones and don't like it very
few I think because it's very popular
but you know it is still clearly
subjective that's number one number two
how do you get a team to be good at
anything when you're scaling your kind
of POV on the world and marketing to a
400
person and downstairs a lot of comments
about downstairs will get their
organization it's about education but I
would actually say that for me scaling
and getting my team to get there has a
lot to do more with osmosis right like
putting it into the water stream versus
having a class that teaches it sure you
can write a book sure we have lunch and
learns and learn ups within the
organization but they're not attended
that well need to talk about that by the
way what's happening more here is people
are doing and people are smart you know
it starts with hiring good people smart
people and then when you realize you've
hired somebody who's not capable of
learning through that process well then
you got to make some decisions but to me
that making good content takes a couple
of core pillars number one you've got to
respect your audience meaning you've got
to respect the psychology of what
they're doing when they're on the
platform I know a 40 year old woman is
in a different mindset when she's on
Facebook versus when she's on Pinterest
and that is how I try to story tell to
her because I know on Pinterest she has
intent to shop aspiration to shop and on
Facebook she's keeping up with her world
or consuming information and so I
strategize around that the psychology
and the platform itself number two when
I say respect I put out content that I
think she will like versus what I'd like
to accomplish yes I'd like to give me a
bottle wine yes I'd like to
a little faster outside no throw yes I'd
like to sell this but if I put it in a
way that is more interesting to her five
under $10 bottles of wine that you know
help you get through the day when you
have eight year old kids and a new
target eight year old kid moms you're
going to start getting into a game that
gives you a better chance you know 12
wines somebody who's 38 will like and
then you target people from that were
born in 1975 these are all strategies
that will work again a very heavy
Facebook or Instagram taking a glamour
shot of it in an angle and it's just
like cool and nice like it's all that
kind of stuff respecting the audience
respecting the platform taking your
agenda and making it third
James asks what are your thoughts on
podcasters and youtubers building a
business model around donations James a
great question you know it's a trend
we've seen for a long time I saw
bloggers do this back in 2003 using
PayPal as a tip jar right there was a
you know this has been a thing that's
been around for a while I think though
as the evolution of the internet is
happening much like the resurgence of
podcasts I see this model in a world of
post Kickstarter becoming more of a
trend I definitely see it as something
that I won't do for myself because I'm
just using my content as a global jab
but I could see myself that if it was
the only thing I did if I was only this
right if I was only the character that I
am when I put on the podcast and the
show meaning when I say character when I
define that for you meaning this is what
I do for a living right I put out my
marketing thoughts like I've had my
career I don't want to be a practitioner
anymore I don't want to run this company
and I just want to write book speak and
put out the show I would probably go
with that kind of model because I need a
sense of and a source of income and more
importantly you start realizing as you
go look like this is a great piece
advice for all of you no matter what you
do sell cheese you know like put out
shows whatever you do and a lot of you
do a lot of different things real estate
you know that 5 to 10 percent that most
give a crap about you boy the
vaynernation
boy that stuff really matters and a lot
of times you can rely on them because
they're getting value I have been blown
away humbled even by the amount of
people who've commented over the last
seven to ten episodes saying things like
man come to realize I'm really into this
show or this is my best part of my day
or this is when I get motivated like you
know it starts becoming valuable and
then I can see the kind of it's a hedge
against I'm charging for this it's kind
of like a guilt move but it's also like
a support me move you know I think it's
I think it's a very viable kind of
attack and and if you're considering it
or anybody here is considering it you
know if you have enough massive loyal
tests you can actually make it valuable
like you only have seven people that
give a crap about you and they give you
dollars a month you got 70 bucks a month
not going to necessarily crush it that
way but if you've got a real big
audience and you can get that five to
ten percent to really support there's
some dollars behind it
hey hunter walk from homebrew we do seed
stage investing and I've got a question
for Gary Gary what's up with virtual
reality what's up with virtual reality
first of all hunter great background as
you guys can tell hunter was in the
office we're talking biz we've done some
mutual investing together he's great BC
a great blogger great Twitter
personality should check him out link
him up during the thing do something do
rock to help too dude anyway hunter it's
a great question I wonder you know it's
funny because I know what you do for a
living unlike me miss hunter looking at
this face you know look I've been
talking and I've been doing this move
and if you're listening I'm putting my
hands in my eyes oculus rift it's coming
you know I very much think that look I'm
in hate predictions but we're getting
close to the end of the year where I
think we're going to force me to do a
prediction show when I say we I mean me
ah I uh 2014 I think by 2024 for sure
that's ten years I think by 2021 VR is
gonna really matter I think video games
television and movies
aka entertainment and I don't want to
get crass but I think porn as well I
think those four categories from a
business standpoint will be heavily
affected by virtual reality and then by
virtue I I see advertising going there
because all of a sudden you can imagine
if I'm playing you know Madden and I
feel like I'm the quarterback and all
the signage around the stadium is now
Lionel Richie root beer wine things of
that nature you can see how advertising
gets filled into it I look I'm in the
eyes and ears business if you want to
know what business I'm in and if you
want to get a cut the rock of a video
clip for a 50 second video for my
youtube channel take this one because
I'm in once and for all like stake in
the ground I am in the eyes and ears
business wherever the eyes and years ago
I go right if I think the ears are
moving quicker and quicker to podcasting
because connected cars are here and
mobile devices are here I start
podcasting get it it's how I move and so
VR is coming as an investor under the
context of you hunter and asking that
question I am look
at it I'm looking at the production
companies the people with the kind of
360 cameras that are going to be in it
video game producers that are going to
play in it I'm a big believer I think
it's a little early and it's definitely
early for mass but I think over the next
three years you'll start seeing kind of
like sprinkles to it and I think five to
seven years from now virtual reality
will have a real place in our society
bigger than people think right now in
the way that you didn't think older
people would take selfies three years
ago that's what I think about VR meaning
a lot of you don't think it's going to
happen I just do Robert says I know you
hate talking about ROI but how do you
show someone there's a true return on
your efforts on social media what how do
you set the question up again I know you
ain't talking I know you hate talking
about ROI
yeah but how do you show someone that
there's a true return on your efforts
Robert I love you for this question B
Rock definitely added this out and make
it one question it's called ROI of your
mother part two because I want to put
this right to bed once and for all the
ROI of your mother concept is to make
fun of traditional media ROI not to get
away from social media ROI I Robert I
love to talk about the ROI of social
media I don't want to run away from it
I'm all in on it once and for all I want
to talk about this
I love ROI I sell stuff it's what I do
nothing matters to me otherwise no
marketing media reports no rewards no Ad
Age mentions that's not what I play for
I want to sell coffee I want to sell
cheese I want to sell wine I want to
sell gadgets I want to sell sweaters I
want to sell you if you let me that's
how I roll and so how do you prove it
you prove it meaning there's a lot of
ways to do and I don't know what you're
trying to sell and I know a lot of brand
managers from big brands kind of follow
me and watch me here I it's very easy to
prove the ROI of social media when we
post the t-shirt that we want to sell
let's link that up by the way I never
got around to posting t-shirt so now
it's 20 bucks not 14 the reverse
engineer thing I apologize vaynernation
up we seen a sales when I post when we
run dark posts for Wine Library we see
the sales when we ran that campaign for
that one organization we got 2,400
signups
versus the 60
sign-ups they got for doing YouTube
videos and billboards and all that and
they spent ten times more there it is
very easy my friend if you have the
direct channel connect what I mean by
that I don't know what that meant it
just spewed but if you can prove it out
on the back end so for example let me
explain for most of the clients we work
with when you're a CPG company and you
sell your product to Walmart and then
they sell it it gets hard to prove the
ROI of a post but when you're Gary
Vaynerchuk and you have winelibrary.com
and you post it and it goes directly
back to you you can see it guys the only
reason I have so much bravado is I'm
seeing the math I come with bravado when
I have intuition right but I'm always
hedging watch my narrative I'm always
like there's something happening here
look what I just did with virtual
reality
I'm nuancing it yes I'm making I'm
hedging but I'm still making a
commitment but the insanity that you've
seen for me on Facebook dark posts or
the emerging sanity on Pinterest is ad
product once it gets a little bit more
price effective in that scale
that's nothing you've seen for me since
maybe 2000 I crash it when I really
believed in YouTube because I was
feeling it guys I'm feeling it right now
how do you prove the ROI you create a
connective tissue to show you that this
thing did that now that's direct
response selling right that's dr and
that's fine i'm a branding guy you need
a mix because if you keep throwing right
hooks it has diminishing returns but
it's never been more easy to prove the
ROI of social media than it is right now
because you can just link it directly to
the dot-com attribution where is you
cannot do that for print outdoor radio
or television it just can you can't do
it in the same exact way you can create
a call to action in those commercials
and you can track it and you can and you
will and that's why those channels
matter still as well but it's very easy
to put a link in any piece of content
even an Instagram where I put in my
headline you guys know what I'm talking
about so you know misnomer
I do like talking about the ROI of
social media I just don't like that it's
not understood that it's more obvious to
track it than it is in traditional and
more importantly I don't want to talk
turn turn all of you into direct
response sellers because then you're far
too much right hooking and
so a lot of times the best pieces of
content are engaging in jabbing where
there is no link out to a call to action
so there's a drop in the correlation of
sales but you're doing the better
overall thing for the brand my friends
it's branding and marketing not just
sales but social media can show you
sales Roberto asks what do you feel is a
bigger obstacle to success a lack of
time or lack of capital Roberto this is
a tremendous question I think the
biggest obstacle to success is a lack of
optimism that question in itself is the
problem my friend right you're looking
at two things that are both negatives
and guess what both of them are
obstacles when I started winelibrary.com
transformation from my business I had
time I've worked my face off every
minute but we didn't have a whole lot of
money in our profit Center so it took
more time right it's just the way it is
today I have more money but boy don't I
have time but neither ever ever will be
an excuse for me and so just a drill
this through the throat of the
vaynernation that's right I went that
graphic don't smile d-roc here's the
bottom line I refuse to allow you to get
an answer to that question because both
of them are firmly Square in the excuse
column and I have no patience for that
there will always be problems let's talk
about a million other things that are a
way to stop success the health and
well-being of your family members so it
takes your mind away from execution the
country you live in government and
political you know concepts at these
moments a la startups in China
that I've invested in that got traction
but then people that were wired into the
government decided to not allow it to
happen and then the startup disappeared
not as easy to be an entrepreneur there
it's still a communist country sorry it
just is and so all these things can be
problems right there's a competitor with
a billion dollars who's also skilled and
punches you in the mouth and knocks you
out in the first round right the world
changing I mean there's just a million
obstacles right the media one bad
coverage of you a moment in time you
know what I think about a lot you know
what I think about a lot let's get
really real this is why we did this show
I always I'm a human being
and I always think about a moment in
time what if I just say the wrong thing
at the wrong time right what if I call
out China for being a communist country
in an episode while I'm on a rant and
somebody who's watching doesn't like the
way that tastes and it takes away a
business opportunity for me in China in
seven years even though I'm not trying
to saying it's just things that I saw
what if what if you know what if what if
I look down on my phone while I'm
driving even though I've really not done
that and I hit somebody and I kill them
and that becomes the story and they like
forget about the story about what you
think of me I will never recover from
that because I killed somebody because I
needed to check a tweet these are
moments in time so there are so many
things that can keep you from being
successful right the people that you
invested in having something bad happen
to them so it slows you down my friends
there are a million reasons why not but
there's one great reason why which is
you've just gotta persevere no matter
what it is it's just the way it is it's
hard being an entrepreneur it's hard
building a business everybody thinks
it's so easy that there's an entitlement
there's a disaster zing in China here
comes my us thing right now there is an
insane generation of 18 to 25 year olds
right now that think they're entitled to
having a business because they saw the
social network movie and everybody's
decided if you're a kid and you know
what tech is because you used Instagram
early on you're entitled to actually
build a business building a business is
hard and you know what makes it really
hard
everything that happens every day of
every moment so you can pick time you
can pick money as the one or two things
that you think stopped you from winning
your game but the truth is there's a
million reasons 99 percent of businesses
go out of business for a reason and that
reason is it's hard and so if you're
watching this show I've got a sense of
who you are and you need to start
creating layers and layers and layers
and layers of skin to be able to get
through because the glamour of being an
entrepreneur the goodness you know you
get very confused by my optimism because
it's my optimism I can't help it it's
just how I roll it's probably one of the
variable 1% reasons why I'm successful
but please don't get it twisted
is hard every day is hard and if you
don't have the stomach to weather the
storm you will not be successful and by
the way let me throw you a real weird
curveball and that's okay people have to
look themselves in a mirror and
understand if they're number two three
four five six seven an organization that
has differences of being a number one
but maybe that's where your skill set
sits maybe that's how you make your
fortunes and happiness and all the
things that you're looking for and so
that question got me going a little bit
Steve because it's endured a context of
excuses and I will never make an excuse
everything that's a problem with me
everything I don't achieve everything
that's a problem at vaynermedia and
everything is my fault and I I succumbed
to that and I respect that
and I actually think that's the way it
should be and so um no excuses my
friends thanks for watching episode 38
it was a driller of an episode kind of
just tight maybe a little bit of anger
from the eight straight losses but a
question of the day very simply what
should I ask here today you know I
actually have a good question but talk
to me talk to me right now about the
thing that is most on your radar over
the next three to five years I talk a
lot about the lack of practicality of a
three to five year plan in today's world
so I don't want to hear your business
plan I'm trying to get a bigger sense of
who you are as a person so give me your
three to five year life plan it's going
to change you'll adjust in six months
but I want you to paint me a picture of
the next 36 to 60 months by the way
would you say the third 11 days
lemon days I'll be 39 just want to
forewarn all of you that when I turned
39 that will begin the process of my
freakout 240 365 days of insanity oh
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe